[Music]
on this Monday night Israel's escalating
crisis and mass protests the outrage
over planned judicial reforms
the Prime Minister says he'll delay the
changes will that quell the anger
attention food Shoppers grocery prices
have gone through the roof haven't they
the rebate coming to offset Rising costs
in Canada whether it's enough and who's
eligible
bail granted two Saskatchewan sisters
convicted of a 1993 murder they say they
didn't commit are released
plus paying tribute everyone should have
a Travis in their lives I will always
remember how excited he was when Brett
found out he was going to be a dad fond
memories of two Fallen Edmonton police
officers
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight in Israel where the Prime
Minister has partially given into
pressure after huge protests across the
country including from his own defense
minister Benjamin Netanyahu has delayed
his highly controversial plans to
overhaul the judicial system which would
give Parliament the power to override
the Supreme Court
what's up
the tens of thousands of people still
believe Netanyahu is behaving like a
dictator and they are demanding he
scrapped the legislation altogether
they're angry too that Netanyahu fired
his defense minister who called the
legislation an immediate and tangible
danger to State security Eric Sorensen
has our top story on the turmoil in
Israel and where it's headed
by this morning the divisions in Israel
were so deep and the protests so large
that the country was on the verge of
economic paralysis and a security
breakdown finally prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu blinked delay in
controversial legislation to overhaul
Israel's Judiciary
out of responsibility to the nation said
Netanyahu he will suspend the law and
give time to reach a consensus it took a
series of dramatic developments
first Israel's defense minister yov
Gallant called for the legislation to be
stopped Netanyahu fired him and that
ignited even more anger
chaos in the knesset saw opposition
lawmakers escorted out streets were
blocked by protesters
labor unions called for a general strike
across the country
flights were canceled at Ben-Gurion
airport even the corporate Community
joined the opposition
labor and the private sector said this
business spokesperson are cooperating
for the first time in history but it
took one more piece idamar Ben gavir the
head of a right-wing party in
netanyahu's Coalition agreed to the
delay in exchange for creating a
national guard under his ministry the
crisis was deflated for now we welcome
this announcement it's a relief to the
international community over a law that
Ottawa 2 has openly questioned we hear
the call of people in the streets of
Israel
and I've been clear to my counterpart
that we are concerned with the judicial
reform that reform would give more power
to the Israeli government and weaken the
Supreme Court's oversight plus critics
say it would protect Netanyahu who was
on trial for corruption he's standing on
trial for criminal charges a fraud of
bribe taking this person could not be in
charge of our democrac the law is only
delayed and Netanyahu says he will take
it up again after Passover at the end of
April I think Netanyahu is playing for
time I think the general strikes
probably surprised him but so far it
seems that he and his Coalition Partners
do want to see this through Israel's top
labor leader has called off the general
strike but warns that if Netanyahu tries
again to push the law through Israelis
will be back on the streets Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
in Germany the transport network was at
a near standstill today because of that
country's largest strike in decades
flights were suspended at eight major
airports in Germany including Munich and
Frankfurt and some commuter and Regional
trains were also canceled two major
transport unions are on a 24-hour strike
they're asking for higher wages to deal
with the High Cost of Living
we have new details tonight about how
the Canadian government intends to spend
money during tomorrow's federal budget
and today in keeping with tradition the
Finance Minister bought herself a new
pair of shoes
I believe they're on sale is that right
they are Christian freelance Troy's
perhaps no surprise given the inflation
crisis to help Canadians deal with
Rising prices the federal government is
expected to roll out what it is calling
a grocery rebate to 11 million Canadian
households Toria isri has the details
the Canadian household budget is pinched
no matter your stage of life last month
of school it's really really getting
tight on the budget grocery prices have
gone through the roof haven't they the
prime minister is pledging to do
something about it in Tuesday's budget a
big part of the budget will be focused
on measures to help Canadians in
targeted ways a senior government Source
says Ottawa is rolling out a so -called
grocery rebate low to modest income
earners will qualify single Canadians
will get 234 dollars while a family of
four will receive 467 dollars from a
policy standpoint I think that makes
sense while it's being called a grocery
rebate economists say it's essentially a
GST Top-Up it's a cash transfer there's
no requirement for anyone to do anything
the money just shows up in your account
if you already receive the GST credits
the NDP supports the move but wants more
spending on health we still want to see
confirmation of the dental care
expansion the Liberals are increasing
resp withdrawals from five thousand
dollars to eight thousand to deal with
the rising cost of Education they're
also unveiling a 30 percent tax credit
for clean tech manufacturing part of a
joint strategy by Canada and the US to
fight climate change and reduce Reliance
on China while inflation is falling the
threat of a recession still looms
Canadians cannot afford to eat heat and
house themselves will he show a little
bit of restraint and commit in
tomorrow's budget to no new taxes we've
demonstrated every step of the way that
we're there to support workers we're
there to support Canadians the Canadian
military is struggling and also looking
for support but it's unlikely the
government will announce new spending on
things like tanks to replace the one
sent to Ukraine or on recruitment to
help with thinning ranks liberal sources
say they're waiting for a defense policy
review to wrap up before making those
decisions and that's expected in the
coming months Donna okay turia Israel
Ottawa thanks we'll have live coverage
of this year's federal budget our
special begins tomorrow at 4 Eastern one
Pacific here on global you can also
watch online at globalnews.ca and on our
other streaming platforms Canada's
auditor general has found big gaps in
how the federal government promises to
spend money and what it actually
delivered in three important areas she
found Global Affairs Canada cannot say
with any confidence if the 3.5 billion
dollars year it spends to improve the
health of women and girls in developing
countries is actually doing that
it is imperative that Global Affairs
Canada immediately act to improve its
information management practices and
Reporting on results
the auditor general also found the
government's efforts to connect people
in rural areas and Indigenous
communities to high-speed internet are
falling short David Aiken reports
the good news is the government has met
its own Target to provide high-speed
internet connections to 90 percent of
the country the bad news as the auditor
general pointed out Monday is that just
60 percent of those in Rural and remote
parts of Canada can get affordable
broadband internet I think it's quite
startling we I've been hearing that
we've been all hearing this from rural
Canada and now the the proof is in the
pudding it's even worse for those living
on First Nations reserves nationally
just 40 percent of households on
reserves are wired up but on the
Prairies it's even more alarming in
Saskatchewan just 10 percent of on
reserve First Nations households are
served by high-speed internet versus 99
of households everywhere else in the
province in Manitoba 15 of on reserve
First Nations households versus 97
percent everywhere else and in Alberta
27 percent versus 99 you can see clear
really that we have a huge huge gap
between
First Nations and the rest of Canadians
in those places added up and that's 1.2
million households who cannot access a
high-speed internet connection to put
that into context for some people that's
like every single person who lives in
the city of Montreal doesn't have
internet access the AG also set our
sights on VIA Rail and other Federal
Transportation agencies saying there are
still too many barriers for people with
disabilities who travel barriers that
impact 2.2 million Canadians when they
ride on a train or a plane some people
in Canada have to constantly fight for
rights that others take for granted as
basic rights the government did get a
passing grade from the AG on the 5
billion dollar project to rehabilitate
Parliament Hills center block concluding
that that project was being quote
effectively managed end quote David
Aiken Global News
Ottawa
former liberal MP Han dong issued a
public statement today saying he intends
to sue Global News and our parent
company chorus entertainment Global News
reported last week that two national
security sources said dong had a
conversation in 2021 with the Chinese
Consul General in which he raised the
cases of Michael kovrig and Michael
spavor and allegedly advised China to
delay their release Dawn confirms he had
the conversation but says he called for
their immediate release the prime
minister's office said dong was not
authorized to speak as a back channel on
the issue and was unaware the
conversation had taken place dong
resigned from the liberal caucus after
the allegations became public because he
says he intends to clear his name Global
News has not received any notice of
legal action from Hong dong
in Quebec two more bodies have now been
recovered from the debris of that
apartment building fire in Old Montreal
seven people were killed when Flames
tore through the Heritage building on
March 16th five of the bodies have been
identified police say no other people
are reported missing but crews are still
searching to ensure there are no more
victims concerns have been raised about
illegal short-term rentals in the
building
in Nashville Tennessee there's been a
mass shooting at a private Christian
Elementary School at least three
children all nine years old and three
adults in their 60s were killed police
say the suspect a 28-year-old woman
armed with two rifles and a handgun is
also dead and that she was a former
student at the school Jackson prosco
reports on the latest Act of gun
violence in the U.S
happened again this time at a private
Christian school in Nashville
police say a 28-year-old woman opened
fire killing three students and three
adults all of the children were age nine
I was literally moved to tears to see
this and
the kids as they were being ushered out
of the building investigators identified
the suspect as Audrey Elizabeth Hale a
former student they say she was armed
with at least two assault rifles and a
handgun she was killed by the first
officers to arrive the officers engaged
her she was fatally shot by responding
police officers investigators say they
recovered a Manifesto and maps of the
school and its security the small
private school was inside a church and
was full of elementary school students
at the time the last place anyone
expected a massacre I don't know how
somebody could
go through with doing something like
that there have been at least 129 mass
shootings involving four or more victims
this year a survivor of another tragedy
the Highland Park Parade shooting in
Illinois happened to be near the
Nashville school at the time
what's happening
why are we
sick
Washington an exasperated president
called on lawmakers to ban assault
weapons that seems unlikely to happen we
have to do more to stop gun violence
it's ripping our communities apart
ripping a soul this nation now as so
many times before an American Community
is reeling as the unthinkable and
preventable takes more innocent lives
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
now to the trail of Destruction and the
ongoing state of emergency in America's
Deep South where at least 26 people are
dead after powerful tornadoes tore
through rural Mississippi and Alabama
over the weekend
enrolling Fork Mississippi there is
nothing left after their tornado that
hit Friday night officials say at least
12 tornadoes have touched down since
then hundreds of people have been
displaced and tonight millions of
Americans from Mississippi all the way
to South Carolina's Coast are bracing
for more severe weather
maintaining their innocence coming up to
Saskatchewan's sisters release after
being convicted of murder nearly 30
years ago
[Music]
in Saskatchewan two indigenous sisters
who say they were wrongly convicted of
murder were granted conditional bail
today after nearly 30 years in prison
narissa and odelia cusants were released
while they await the results of a
ministerial review of the case Melissa
ridgeen reports
right now I'm just overwhelmed and I
just want to go be with my family thank
you I'm in shock like no emotions but I
always knew in my heart will be free
today for the first time in three
decades odelia and narissa kuzans can
hold hands and walk together from the
same Courthouse where they received life
sentences for a murder a case that's
under review a judge ruled Monday they
should be released on bail while that
takes place we're very happy with the
result
and it's great to see a dealer in
narissa free
it's been a very long time for them the
sisters were convicted in the death of
70-year-old Anthony Dolph at his
Farmhouse near kamsak Saskatchewan in
1993. they were 19 and 21 at the time
drinking with Dolph and their 14 year
old cousin
the elderly farmer is said to have
propositioned the girls soon after he
was beaten to death something the
sisters say they didn't do their cousin
admitted to it and spent four years in
Youth detention Canada's most notable
exonerie David Milgard advocated for the
women before his death last year along
with Senator Kim Pate who wants the
women exonerated this is a a big step on
route to the uh to The Minister's
eventual decision because the purpose of
this is to get the convictions quashed
so that their names declared for now
they'll enjoy Freedom while the federal
review takes place that's expected to
take a year or more Melissa ridgeen
Global News
maternal malnutrition ahead how food
insecurity is affecting mothers in
crisis hit countries
[Music]
getting proper nutrition is critical
during pregnancy for mothers who live in
countries where food is scarce and
expensive that can be a challenge a
report by UNICEF spells out the
countries at the epicenter of a
malnutrition crisis exacerbated by the
ongoing drought in the Horn of Africa
plus conflict and political instability
Catherine Ward reports on the effects
food insecurity has on future
Generations
we are witnessing the largest global
food and nutrition crisis in modern
history looking over the numbers Vilma
Tyler thinks of each woman represented
among them trying her hardest to get
food if there's limited food in the
household women will be the last ones to
eat women will prioritize the men and
their children before they can eat a new
report from UNICEF shows the extreme
effect malnutrition is having on mothers
and their children the report
highlighted challenges in a dozen
countries in Africa and the Middle East
it found acute malnutrition among
pregnant women and breastfeeding mothers
increased 25 percent in the past two
years globally UNICEF estimates 51
million children under 2 years old are
too short for their age because of poor
nutrition in the first six months of
life
the World Health Organization says iron
folic acid and vitamin A are needed
daily for the health of the mother and
fetus but ensuring access is a challenge
obedema as a zika travels to help
communities with nutrition programs he
says Investments have a direct link to
long-term health and economics if
there's a deficiency in these
micronutrients what happens to the
children feels like stunting or on doing
it leads to low brain development a life
and death fight experts say needs a
unified approach recalling for world
leaders to spend more allocate more of
their fiscal budgets to address women's
health and nutrition issues something
that should be invested in because
you're not just focusing on the women
you're also focusing on The Unborn
children as well Catherine Ward Global
News Toronto
saying goodbye next friends and family
gather for the funeral of two Fallen
Edmonton police officers
[Music]
a regimental funeral was held today for
the two Edmonton police officers killed
in the line of duty earlier this month
thank you
Constable's Travis Jordan and Brett Ryan
were remembered by those who loved them
and who worked alongside them Heather
York's West reports on the tribute to
the fallen officers
they marched in the bitter cold
escorting their fallen colleagues to the
place where their friends and family
would say a final goodbye a somber
procession that Canadian Police Service
members have come to know all too well
while thousands of police officers and
other First Responders representing 45
agencies from across North America
joined the families inside Roger's Place
members of the public were invited to
take in the funeral service via a live
stream outside among the crowd Jennifer
Henning whose husband works with the
Edmonton Police he was working the night
that it happened so
um we support him we support all the
business brothers and sisters in blue
one wife grieving for two others inside
Annie Jordan wrote a tribute to her
husband standing on stage as it was read
on her behalf
Travis
my police officer my best friend it's
been the biggest honor being your wife
Constable Brett Ryan's wife Ashley is a
first responder who was present the
night her husband lost his life the
couple is expecting their first child I
will always remember how excited he was
when Brett found out he was going to be
a dad I know you have already met our
baby and you will forever be their angel
you will live on in Baby Ryan and they
will know every last detail about how
special you were
two husbands sons and friends who will
be remembered for not just their
sacrifice for the love that filled their
lives I love you forever I'll miss you
always and I love you more
until we meet again
Heather urich's West Global News
Edmonton
and we leave you tonight with more
images from the procession in Edmonton
today ahead of the funeral for those two
officers killed while doing their jobs
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]